ich verspreche euch das ja ist ein
echtes rock video denn bülent ceylan
wird das einmalige experiment vollführen
wie oft kann er seine haare um die nase
wickeln das war eine frage aus der
community und noch viel mehr jetzt im
community video mit bachelor viel spaß
enabled to kill you möchte wissen hast
du eine inspirationsquelle
inspiration sind
emil steinberger schweizer kabarettist
der bodenständigkeit er michael
mittermeier
heinz er hat damals in den 50er 60er
jahren der wahnsinnig geil award spiel
gemacht hat also da gibt es ein paar die
ich gerne angeguckt habe und auch home
entertainment fand ich rudi carrell
immer ganz gut er war immer super
vorbereitet und hat das alles hat alles
war wirklich ein sehr
hat sein handwerk genau gewusst wie wir
das wieder sein heil willens und hynix
um meine fahrer nicht ist wie bist du
auf den gedanken kommen irgendwann mal
comedian zu werden und wie hast du es
geschafft in die medien zu kommen du
hast ja dann eigene fernsehsendung auf
rtl und wie hast du das alles geschafft
das ist meine erste frage ja wie ich
komm medien geworden bin war das
also eigentlich war ich auch schon immer
musiker irgendwo und aber als kind weil
sie noch habe ich meine mutter zum
lachen gebracht aber was irgendwie
traurig oder so und dann habe ich
gemerkt ich musste irgendwie zum lachen
zu bringen so und hat die gut gelacht
aus der seele raus und hab ich gemerkt
wie es ist schön andere wahl zum lachen
bringen natürlich hab ich als kinder
nicht gedacht wird mal komiker aber dann
in der schule auf dem schulfest habe ich
auch viel stimme limitiert und so boris
becker helmut kohl und so weiter und ich
auf dem schulfest elfte klasse weist 16
17 oh ja und dann habe ich dann auf dem
abiball habe ich ja noch mal ein
bisschen comedy gemacht und dann bis ins
radio und dann habe ich aber auch
studierenden noch ne band gehabt und
irgendwie hat es dann doch geklappt ich
auf der bühne so kleinkunstbühne dann
mal angefangen habe und und dann bin ich
in hamburg
beim gipfelstürmer festival damals das
sind so 55 besten nachwuchskünstler
bundesweiter eingeladen worden und da
war ich einer davon und und durch
agentur entdeckt und ja und ab dem
zeitpunkt links denn so professionell
wie jetzt 14 jahre dabei ist war ein
langer weg aber ein guter weg und ja die
mit den medien wie habe ich mir ja
bülent ceylan show geschafft das war so
das natürlich dass ein langer weg war
weil es gab kaya yanar zehn jahre lang
monopol und dann auf einmal war die
schublade irgendwie bedient deutschland
wir haben einen türken und dann muss ich
da richtig
durch kämpfe so nach dem motto aber
nicht alle türken machen das gleiche
programm also und dann habe ich aber
irgendwann mal die medien überzeugt und
so nach dem motto ich bin der rocker der
mannheimer türken rocker ja und dann kam
das irgendwann mit der bülent ceylan
show das war dann
war dann der nächste schritt um eine
zweite frage ist würdest du sagen wir
mal wenn du kein wort mehr haft auf
fernsehen würdest du dann mal deine
videos auf youtube machen oder hättest
du da gar keinen bock drauf würdest du
dann sagen ich habe schluss jetzt macht
gar nicht mehr weiter also ich weiß
nicht dass youtube ist ja eh schon viele
sachen wenn auf youtube gepostet also
ich hab da nichts dagegen und so weiter
und gewinnen das ist hilft ja auch sehr
oft und man trifft wie sagt man viele
junge zuschauer gucken es ja auch
hauptsächlich
und ja mal gucken also wie das läuft ich
würde gerne mal beides gemachten
internet und fernsehen die vier
gesichter fragen hey bulent wie oft
kannst du deine haare um deine nase
drehen das musste ich mal machen wie oft
ich meine haare um die nase trinken
also ich weiß nicht wie das
funktionieren soll ich glaube es gibt
nur einmal
hallo christoph hallo bilanz ich habe
eine frau die heavy metal frage und zwar
was ist ein rekord in headbangen also
meiner liegt bei 31 sekunden und mich
wenn man so viel du das überboten hast
oder wir bieten kannst ja also dass die
frage stellen wie lange zeit bringen
kann
ich hab früher als teenager habe ich
sehr lange hält wegen des teilweise ein
ganzes lied durch also und so normale
rock wie das geht noch so zwischen drei
und fünf minuten locker und sie habe ich
mal durchgegangen haben teilweise
mehrere lieder hintereinander geld
bringt und das war also war ich am
nächsten tag auch da habe ich so einen
steifen nacken gehabt also das war
teilweise richtig so wenig ruhm gelaufen
daher konnte ich habe richtig schmerzen
gehabt meistens dann nach der disco
jetzt auf der bühne bin ich zwar immer
noch aber
nicht so lange wie du jetzt als 30
sekunden am stück ist schon ist schon
lange italia 2 1.000 meine frage ein
bülent was war der peinlichste moment
deines lebens ist die peinliche momente
gibt es mehrere aber einer war wo ich
zu den zuschauern auf der bühne dann
sagt sie ist jetzt so frau mit dem man
neben dran und ich sagte wow schön es
ist deine mama dann sagte er nein das
ist meine frau
und
das war ein scheiß gefühl
ist ja nun mal bin ich nicht mehr aus
also ganz schwer ist es war mir einfach
peinlich waren die andere erste reihe
gesessen waren also da wie kann ich auch
nicht mehr richtig zum lachen bringen
deswegen aber mein gott das waren
wirklich über 20 jahre unterschied aber
es gibt ja auch halt dass ältere frauen
auch die männer haben aber beim türken
gibt es nicht aber unzählige haye will
land hey christoph wir sind die jungs
von you think i und wir haben zwei
fragen an dass die erste frage wäre
wieso hast du dein studium abgebrochen
und komiker zu werden was ist da
passiert ich habe das studium
erfolgreich abgebrochen
weil ich einfach weil ich gemerkt habe
die comedy das ist das ist das ist mein
ding und ich habe politik philosophie
studiert und da kannst ersten prognose
street insofern das war für mich absolut
der richtige weg und die zweite frage
wäre dann für wen oder was würdest du
deine haare abschneiden was muss man
dafür
grabstein würde ich nie machen ich will
niemals die haare abschneiden ist erst
wenn du mir millionen euro da hinlegen
würde ich einfach nicht machen weil das
bin ich also ich habe hier schon form
von meinem bekannt sein habe ich lange
haare gehabt weil es einfach das ist
eine einstellungssache das bin ich
bühnen ist einfach lange haare und wenn
sie einfach von natur aus immer mal
ausfallen würden ja mein gott in salla
hoffentlich nie unsere abschließende
frage an dich fühlen kannst du auch so
einen guten roman handschin lars
kannst du
ich habe zwar früher sport leisten
gehabt und ich kann zwar an stand aber
so lang wie das ist 20 sekunden aber
krank
das kann ich nicht ich gebe mich zu du
bist der gewinner the legend mario
möchte wissen fühlst beziehungsweise
siehst du dich eher als deutscher oder
als türke da ich ja mitbekommen habe
dass du nicht allzu gut türkisch kannst
aber dein programm ja zu 70 prozent aus
türkischen humor besteht naja 70 prozent
ist es nicht aber es ist
es ist schön dass du das so sieht also
ich sehe es immer so etwas anders aber
ich meine das ist ja okay das ist ja
auch gut so das sind auch meine wurzeln
aber wie ich mich fühle vater ist türke
mutter durch ich fühle mich erstmal gut
ich bin so ein bisschen halt beträgt
also wenn ich zum beispiel sagen ein
beispiel wenn ich ein schnitzel bestellt
dann kann ich halt nur ein halbes
schnitzel bestellen weil mein vater ist
ein moslem mutter katholisch also
deswegen schwein und rechts davon wohnen
aber ein halbes schnitzel geht wegen der
mama deswegen stelle ich immer halt
immer nur die hälfte und noch mehr
community videos gibt es jetzt hier zum
anklicken zum beispiel dass in den
summer jam der darüber spekuliert dass
sich bushido frieden erkauft mit den
versöhnungen mit denen er jetzt am start
ist und eine davon auch community video
ist sie mit alpa gun er erzählt darüber
warum wann wie wo er sich mit bushido
versöhnt hat er könnte beide angucken
und ein von beiden oder oder oder
ansonsten bis dann